the i-team has learned that former nfl  player and unlv rebel  has been arrested adam seward is accused  of crashing  into a pole and leaving the scene then  dropping the passenger off  at the hospital in a separate car an  arrest report states she had several  injuries  including fractures stewart is facing a  felony charge and two misdemeanors  his attorney josh tomczyk sent the  i-team a statement which reads in part  mr sheward immediately drove the alleged  victim to the nearest hospital  at her request therefore mr sheward  cooperated with law enforcement in their  investigation  steward was a member of the carolina  panthers and jacksonville jaguars  you can find his attorney's full  statement along with more  on this story at 8 news now dot com